i was working from home at the time and
i had a knock on the door
open the front door as i would to
anybody and instantly received about a
pint of concentrated sulfuric acid
to the face uh whilst an unknown man
said
this is for you mate he was stood in a
step two steps down from my doorstep so
he threw it in an upright motion so the
acid came up
and it hit the ceiling above me and
rained down my back
my t-shirt disintegrated from top to
bottom and was hanging on my arms like a
waistcoat
that was the moment i knew it was acid
andres's attacker
david phillips had driven 300 miles from
sussex to cornwall
to carry out a revenge attack but this
was a case
of mistaken identity he had got
the wrong man phillips had his life
sentence quashed in 2016
and andreas has now been told his
attacker has been moved to an open
prison
and is applying for day release a little
over
five years since the attack took place
second i think is probably the correct
term
it became very obvious that in the uk
you can throw a pint of sulfuric acid in
someone's face
ruin their life cost them physically
emotionally mentally cost the state
hundreds of thousands if not millions in
hospital fees and police investigations
and then he spent
five and a half years behind actual bars
it just doesn't add up andreas says he
feels
let down by the justice system every
aspect of my life
has been affected by what he did to me
every aspect
there isn't one aspect that hasn't been
affected even sleeping
how can he be out yes he's still at an
open prison but he can go out and enjoy
the sunshine
he can go out and spend time with his
family he can even go and get a job
and start working again when i'm still
picking up the pieces from what he did
to me
the government says that since this
appalling attack
it has increased minimum custodial
sentences
too late for andreas whose attacker is
now regaining his freedom
while andreas continues to rebuild his
life
i'd like to make the most of life you
know even if i am
disabled in the way i am because what
david phillips did to me i still
pick myself up and carry on doing what i
can do it's not what i want to be doing
but it's it's something
so life is it's good you know you know
it's the best it can be in a in a bad
situation
dan whitehead sky news in cornwall